one of the blessings of
employing your students is that they
never seem to grow up
Tim's a father and a Dynamo and runs a
significant part of Hillsdale College
but he's still a kid to me
uh
so I want to start with two facts
um
they are the signal facts and the change
in the American constitutional practices
the first is that we don't make our laws
through elected legislators anymore
and that's the worst No-No that uh if
you just read the article article one
two and three of the Constitution all in
the first sentence this a certain power
in a certain body
legislative executive and judicial
but only Article 1 says all the
legislative power
shall be vested in a congress
but of course congress makes this
minority of our laws now
and that means that there can be so many
of them Congress actually makes about
the same number of laws per year
as it made in 1840
and it's still got that stupid ugly
wonderful process but for making them
that involves compromise and
forever discussion and debate
and the fact that it hamstrings
Expedition is one of its Hallmarks
but not in the bureaucracy
that is complicated but there are I mean
literally there are millions of people
who work in it
and they work night and day well they
don't work very hard but they work night
and day
so that's a change see Madison writes if
the laws be so voluminous and changing
that they it does not matter if they're
made by the right process it's still not
law
because you can't keep up with it
and if Locke you know I can tell you
from managing a college
the first step in a successful
relationship and we take that step with
everybody who enters our college at
every level
is they have to adopt the goals
through an honor code for the students
through code of commitment for the
faculty and the staff
and it's voluntary there are a lot of
places to work you want to work here
this is what this is for
and that means that we're all on the
same page and we that can all help both
make and enforce the law
that's the first change and the second
change is centralized now
uh
things are done remotely
and there's a time in American history
where that had no prestige
tocqueville writes that the principles
of America as regards Administration are
each person is the best judge of the
matters that concern mainly himself
and similarly each locality is the best
judge of the things that concern mainly
itself
and he says that that gives rise to a
spirit
and the spirit is that uh
we think that we should run the society
the government
he says the government is bigger in
America than in France the first big
nation state
but it's local and voluntary in its
nature
if you remove it a distance
then that changes everything it means
that the people who make the law are not
near the scene of action
uh the Constitution United States the
effect of it
was decentralized power in some ways but
also to complicate the powers so that
there could be more elaborate separation
of powers
and it was only the national things
and you know they're in Article 1
Section 8 and they are contained in 1617
paragraphs
and they basically break down into these
groups
National Defense which is half of the
16.
a national system of Commerce
we're all going to trade with each other
all we want without
boundaries of state borders
and I think uh previous speaker made the
point that the founders were not
free Traders
they were kind of but certainly not
purely
uh and then the third thing is the
federal government didn't have any
territory
so it needed the right to operate on
certain lands where it would have post
offices and the nation's capital and
that's the federal government that's all
of it
and that was all of it for the great
you know for the first 175 years of
American history
so if it's
laws are now made by people who do not
directly report to us
and they're made in a centralized way a
long way from the scene of action last
night I gave an example of that
I've become increasingly appalled
by the way Education Works uh if you go
into that line of work you
learn something about it and and
mostly when you look at what's done you
think well that's stupid
that could never work right well uh
since 2000 and this is true by the way
in red States and blue States
the number of students in the public
schools have grown seven and a half
percent the number of teachers has grown
eight and a half percent and the number
of Administrators mostly in school
districts has grown 92 percent
and that's horrific because the nature
of the thing
National Defense has a nature and it is
you got to gather yourself up a whacking
big old army and
resources from all over the country
if you're going to fight China which
might be the next thing
and that's its nature that's what you
have to do
but education it has a nature and the
nature is
each person learns
the main work of learning is in the soul
of the one who learns and that's without
exception
I mean I mean there isn't even even a
moment where that's not true
and so education is decisively a local
thing
also uh
for young children
College age children they're just at
that wonderful age where you can just
beat the hell out of them and their
parents and their parents are nowhere
around
but uh
but little kids you know they have to be
cared for by people who make the
craziest commitment in the world
you know if you if we were bears and had
Bear Cubs or dogs and we had puppies
we'd be with them a few weeks no this is
a third of Our Lives more we spend on
these kids
and they need us right and then they
need teachers because it's in the nature
of the thing
that
when you have a question
it's better to get it answered right
then
and the process this is what a seminar
is that's why it's the most glorious way
to learn it's really beautiful and the
reason is everything that everybody says
diverts the discussion to something new
and that means everybody is helping to
make the class
so to take the resources and the
authority and move them out of the
school
to a place miles hundreds of miles often
away
and Repose them in the hands of people
who don't go into classrooms and teach
that's just a devastating thing to do
and there's no example of it in American
history until modern times
and it changes things now it it unlocked
the most wonderful possibilities from a
certain point of view
it means that there's this huge
bureaucracy
you know the first big political union
is the teachers union started in
Michigan actually
and uh you know we we're not universally
a blessing to the union
and uh
uh
what is the spirit of those unions
because first of all it's difficult to
know what they do isn't it
what is a district official do in the
school system
if you if you you can look it up if you
want to it's not a hard state budget
I'll always have a list of what the jobs
are
and the jobs titles are obscure
so like history teacher that's not
obscure
school principle that's not obscure
uh
I can't even think of any of the names
they don't appeal to the common sense
but they have words like facilitator and
coordinator
and there's scads of them and they make
up more than half the employees of the
public schools
and I think that it must be the spirit
of them
and the reason I think this the spirit
of them is
they have teacher Envy
because a teacher is a highly respected
thing
my father was a school teacher in
Pocahontas Arkansas and he was a highly
respected man
and he found his happiness in that
little town and people and when he was
dying and died people lectured me about
how important he was and I had better
understood that and I would say well he
was my dad
and they'd say yeah but you're a big
fancy pants academic now you probably
don't understand anymore
if if so you see that that
that's where the prestige is
it's just like in the military by the
way
the one who actually holds the gun
I was on the board of the army war
college and it's for colonels
who are hoping to be generals it's
really cool place George Washington
served in that spot
and I liked all the kernels and some of
the generals
because you know there's a filtering
process right most of the kernels don't
ever get to be generals and a fair
number of the ones who do are good at
politics
whereas anybody who's commanded troops
in the field Under Fire
it doesn't matter if the chief of staff
of the Army is in the conversation
that's the person who has prestige
well what we've done is we've made the
whole thing top heavy and the people up
at the top are resentful I think and
that's one reason why they're so loyal
to their unions and that's another
reason why because their jobs are purely
a creature of Regulation
whereas you know you need School
teachers
somebody's going to have to help the
kids learn you can if you homeschool
that'll take a lot of time
and parents soon enough for forming
co-ops so they can share the load right
because it's work and it's real work and
it's important work
whereas the district facilitator of
whatever the hell they facilitate
now the point is
you can take this these facts about
education that are shocking
oh I mentioned last night Sarah Sanders
Sarah Huckabee
I know her dad and uh we're from
Arkansas which means we're cousins and
and uh
the students at the college have a thing
going now that uh they're demanding that
I put together an Arkansas night
where the governor and her father the
governor and Senator cotton a friend of
mine and I are on a panel so they can
inquire of us how we are in fact related
it's a story of inbreeding
um
but uh
she you know I think she's a ball of
fire several of these Governors are I'm
going to mention them and she
is working I hear from Senator cotton
who talks to her
because you know cousins in public
office
and uh he said that the let many in the
legislature in Arkansas are looking for
a way to curtail the number of people in
the bureaucracy you know in Arkansas
and that's you know that's
God's work and I have never
I've been doing this a long time
the first movement in that direction
that I am seeing in my life of any
significance is now
and that's a very hopeful thing
my friend Doug Jeffrey my longest
serving colleague if you count back in
Claremont John cervini is the longest
serving employee of the college
uh
he he he thinks I'm an incredible weenie
um
but I'm just tough enough that he can
put up with me
and so
he doesn't like all the politicians I
like
whereas I do like all the ones he likes
I think
so I'm going to talk about some
Governors that are not entirely popular
with him I don't think
but the point I'm going to make is very
important point
and that is
there's a new politics
and it may be too late it may be I mean
this is a very bad thing what's going on
here
um
and it's worth wondering why all this
has happened because we could be
overcome by this stuff now we could be
overcome by it in the intermediate term